hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between thomas wilson barnes and
paul charles murphy in the previous game
barnes defeated paul murphy by playing
f6 on the first move
uh so uh naturally we want to see what
happens in the next game and this is a
one such
game also a very enjoyable one so let's
just dive straight into it
uh this time barnes with the white
pieces opens with
e4 uh morphe goes for e5 as morphe
usually does we have knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5
barnes goes for the roy lopez we have
knight to f6 the berlin defense
and d4 now just striking in the center
we have e
captures and now e5 so what do you play
here uh morphe goes for
knights to e4 uh we have castles by
barnes uh not a stranger to
the theory of the time uh and a6 now
challenging
uh barnes is a bishop on b5 we have
bishop to
a4 and now knight to c5 re-maneuvering
the knight
while also attacking the bishop here now
you either go to b3 and then face d5
which will be
which will be very nice for black or you
go into bishop captures on c6 which is
something that's played even today so
the captures by morphe and now
knight captures on d4 grabbing back his
pawn now morphy's king is still in the
center of the board so of course he
wants to develop in castle
uh we have bishop to e7 now preparing
the castle
and knight the c3 by barnes we have
castles by morphe
and bishop to e3 barnes just continues
developing
and now morphy goes for f6 morphy said
if it
worked for barnes in the previous game
it's gonna work in this game i'm i'm
sure of it
and barnes says okay uh e captures on f6
we have rook captures now
uh not worrying about bishop g5 bishop
g5 then you
no longer defend the knight just rook d6
will come with a double attack on the
knight here and
black doesn't really have much to worry
about so instead
we have queen to e2 by barnes freeing up
the d1 square for the rook
uh and now morphy goes rook to g6 and
here it's a very
uh very dynamic position morphe has the
two bishops are really firing up that
uh king side this this bishop is
probably coming to d6 to go after this
point then the queen can come to h4
uh and so on and already if you make
like a slow move rook 81 then bishop
h3 immediately comes with an attack
since the g pawn is pinned
so uh barnes says okay king h1 a nice
prophylactic move
uh and here we have bishop to d6 morphy
just switches the bishop over to
uh to this attacking diagonal uh but
this position
has been reached uh even in modern chess
for example in 2001
uh it uh appeared in the game bucklers
versus krishnan sasekiran in part of its
open
uh where black won the game with b5
however uh in those days morphe
continued with bishop to d6
and it is uh as of move 14 that this
position has never been reached again
and now the bishop is on this a very
nice diagonal the queen can come to age
four threaten some checkmating ideas uh
and so on
so barnes goes for rook 8 to d1 he puts
his
rook in front of morphy's queen and
morphe immediately moves it with a
deadly threat of just queen captures an
h2 checkmate
and you have to be careful if you play
some like h3 just bishop captures
and your whole position just falls apart
of course the bishop cannot be captured
because of queen captures with checkmate
so barnes goes for f4 and it is uh
it's a good move blocks the bishop
completely
and in the future you might have some
ideas of of going even f5 and
and even further so here we have bishop
to g4 by morphe attacking the queen and
now if you don't want to lose the rook
behind the queen
knight to f3 also possible with queen to
c for check
uh so queen to h5 uh now putting more
pressure uh
well on that uh knight end on the queen
but just
bishop captures on c5 but and you also
you have to
be be careful like rook to h6 is coming
with the threat of just removing the
defender of the h2 square
uh which will force barnes to make uh
further concessions on his
kingside defenses so here barnes comes
up with
bishop captures on c5 and it is in fact
the strongest move recommended by the
engine
morphic captures back bishop captures
and now knight the e4 this is how he
brings back uh the knight into the
attack
uh attacking the bishop so morphy of
course doesn't want to lose it he goes
bishop to b6 and now knight
e to g5 here barnes created a very
deadly threat which i'm
i'm certain most of you can see but just
in case
uh let's pretend morphy played something
like rook to f8 do you see how barnes
wins the game on the spot uh you even
take a few seconds uh while i while i
give you a few seconds
to pause the video
uh so congratulations to everyone who
immediately found the smothered mate
and just in case someone just wants to
enjoy the show it's queen c4 check
and now there's nothing much to be done
you can either give up material with
bishop e6 but that just loses material
without any compensation
or you go for the absolute best
smothered mate a double check now from
the
knight and the queen your only move is
this then you sacrifice the queen
captures and of course knight f7
delivers checkmate just in case
some of you have never seen this one but
this is the threat and morphy plays h6
he makes some room for his king on h7
uh and okay we have queen to c4 by
barnes this comes with
check king h8 and knight to f7 check now
preparing to shift the knight over to e5
now king h7
as morphe created this square for the
king and now
uh barnes goes for knight the e5 with an
attack on the bishop and under rook
however
there was the f5 in the position it's a
it's a very nice move
so i'm gonna show it point is that the
rook is now under attack and you don't
really have a lot of good squares for
the rook
and also if you capture on f5 then you
just get
knight to e5 uh attacking the rook and
now
you have to give up the rook otherwise
if you move let's say rook f6 g4 comes
with a double attack here as now both
the the knight and the queen guarded the
g4 pawn
so f5 was in the position however barnes
went for
uh this 95 move he attacks the rook and
the bishop
we have bishop rook to f6 now getting
the rook out of harm's way and now comes
knight the g4 again f5 was extremely
strong here for barnes uh because
there's a double attack on the bishop
now
and you have to again if you capture
just g4 wins material
and if you don't let's say you play
something like captures then rook
captures this is nicely defended and
you have ideas like knife g4 kicks the
rogue back f6
is coming uh and so on so could have
been
could have gone very well for barnes
however barnes captures the bishop on g4
and now we have queen captures on g4 by
morphe and now
knight to e5 so out of the two and out
of the games we've seen
uh we kind of realize who the attacker
between the two is here i mean morphy is
always an attacker but barnes is just
barnes is just uh you know one one crazy
dude
so we have queen to e6 now morphy offers
a trade of queens as
uh well he is uh he is behind in uh you
know in
in uh the controlled space so he really
wants to
get the queens off the board uh but
barnes refuses queenie for check so
morphy blocks again
uh and now uh barnes captures uh uh
otherwise if you move the queen to some
sort of a silly square you might lose
the c2 pawn and so on
so here barnes trades we have rook
captures and now g4 pushing morphy's
rook back we have rook to f6
and now only now f5 creating a nice
outpost for the knight on g6
and restricting the movement of this
rook of course so morphe brings the
other rook into the game but now
knight the g6 and here's a very uh fun
moment in the game here when i was
checking out the game for the first time
i thought
uh yeah you definitely don't want to
play something like rook to e2 because
then rook to d8 comes and you you have a
lot of problems on your back rank but
the funny thing is this is exactly what
morphe plays morphe says
activity above all and he he actually
invites barnes to go rook to d8 which
barnes does
so barnes goes rook to d8 and he
threatens mate in one
uh and the only thing for morphe lift is
to give up the exchange here which is
what morphe does so rook captures
we have f captures with check king
captures and now
rook to d7 here barnes is preparing uh
rook to f7 followed by captures and the
well
just an uh an all-out onslaught uh
towards the black king
so here rook captures on c2 uh very
important
to start grabbing those spawns with rook
f2f7
and now morphe just defends it with
bishop to d4 and it's a it's a it's a
critical move because now the pawn is
defended and you cannot capture it
because morphy just wins back the rook
so really really crazy stuff so barnes
starts grabbing the pawns
rook captures on c7 but morphy does the
same while also
kind of defending but not really so
barnes captures on b7 and we have rook
captures on a2 and all of a sudden
morphe is still down the exchange but
he's up to pawns
so how what can what can barnes do about
this barnes goes for h4 he wants to
somehow constrict the movement of the
black king and he is successful in doing
so so
uh if uh mor if barnes somehow uh
gets close to the king with those rooks
it could be dangerous however with the
dark square bishop guarding the g7 pawn
it's very unlikely that this will happen
so morphy just starts pushing his pass
pawn
we have a7 by morphe and now h5 check we
have king to g5
and now it's already getting very
dangerous if this king comes all the way
here
uh and the bishop guards the the g1
square then rook to h2 could be some
sort of a checkmate
so here barnes uh well again for the
lack of a better move
uh decides to give up give back the
exchange so rook captures on g7
uh but morphy says i'm not interested in
your rook he just goes king h4
and now what do you play here well uh
there's a uh
there are a lot of things you can play
uh but barnes decided to go for rook
g to e7 had he played rook g to d7 the
game still continues however he played
rook g to e7
and now the game is completely lost uh
it's actually a forced
checkmate in eight for paul morphy and
that's uh
with the absolute best defense for black
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find the quickest way to victory for
morphe while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on looking
on the other side side of the board and
for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's not
king h3 if you play king h3 just rook b3
check forces the king back so you don't
have this nice checkmate
but you're not completely wrong if you
were thinking king h3 because you want
to prepare king h3 and the way you
prepare king h3
is by playing a4 and this is what morphy
played and it was in this
position that uh thomas wilson barnes uh
resigned the game
as now uh checkmate is coming and it's
actually a very quick one just king h3
followed by rook to h2 checkmate however
with best defense it's actually
a now with a for played a forced
checkmate in seven
so how how white could force this is the
well to play some funny moves like rook
b3 he can give up a rook
but uh it's uh not not the greatest of
defenses
but it is funny so we'll show it so he
can grab it and now he puts the other
rook here he still needs access to the
b3 square if king h3 he wants to kick it
away with rook captures
but now we get b2 and now again we have
some very nice ideas here so now rook b4
and we have c5 now attacking the rook so
again you can't capture this because
just b1
uh queen or rook delivers checkmate
so rook to b6 let's say and now comes c4
and now with c4 played again you gain
control of the b3 square and now it's
game over whatever black plays let's say
rook b7
now you go king h3 and that's it now
white again needs to give up the rook
with
check we will capture this and now it's
almost stalemate as the king and the
bishop are doing a nice job
boxing in the white king but white has
this g5 move unfortunately
and then uh well pretty much anything
here is mate you can play this you can
play this you can bring a queen
you can bring a rook into the game it's
all checkmate uh but it all came down to
this beautiful a4 move morphe founded of
course and
barnes resigned the game uh so yeah
uh fourth game where we've shown between
paul charles murphy and
thomas wilson barnes i do hope you
enjoyed it as there are plenty more to
come
and not all games were recorded uh
if you remember me saying that but those
that are are very exciting and
we are going to show most of them and if
by any chance you are new to the paul
morphy saga there's always a link in the
description
that you can you can just start the
entire saga from the beginning
so you don't miss anything on the great
genius that is paul charles morphy
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank christian van der
decker
uh glenn frankenberger muhammad already
matthew wilkinson and
ben clements for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the paul
morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day
oh and uh sorry about the weird sounds
in the previous video
i forgot to turn off the notification on
obs that that's why it happened
see you soon